In this video, we'll review some best practices for organizing your Unreal Engine project.
Despite Unreal Engine 5 introducing a large open-world concept with world partition,
for smaller levels like this one, a persistent level with sublevels is still recommended.
A persistent level often persists throughout the entire game session,
while sublevels are children of the persistent level and can be turned on and off or streamed
or unstreamed as needed throughout a project. So in the persistent level,
we mostly try to keep everything that is going to persist throughout the entire project,
key lights for example, cameras, any kind of environmental assets, and then anything that
only needs to come up as needed throughout the project, we'll put those on sublevels and
bring those in only as needed. In the case of this project, we're actually quite comfortable
keeping all of it entirely in the persistent level. When organizing your content browser,
be sure to use folders as a way to structure the different needs of the project and do the
same thing in your project outliner, putting key assets in different folders by category,
which can then be toggled on and off even at the outliner level without having to put them
into separate sublevels. A nested folder structure is often recommended, folders inside folders
with parent folders being more broad categories and the nested folders being more specific to
particular needs and subcategories. In the next video, we'll go over some tips and additional
resources you can use as you expand your knowledge of OSC for your own projects.